>> Sean: BREAKING NEWS EARLIER
THIS EVENING.
THE HOUSE INTEL COMMITTEE
RANKING MEMBER DEVIN NUNES SENT
A LETTER TO THE NSA, THE CIA AND
FBI DEMANDING ANSWERS ABOUT
JOSEPH MISFUD.
REMEMBER, THIS IS THE
"PROFESSOR" WHO TOLD GEORGE
PAPADOPOULOS THAT THE RUSSIAN HE
HAD DIRT ON HILLARY CLINTON.
REMEMBER THE STORY?
GEORGE PAPADOPOULOS WILL BE
JOINING US.
JOINING US TO EXPLAIN IS
CONGRESSMAN DEVIN NUNES.
THANK YOU.
THE BREAKING NEWS.
I HAVE THE FULL COPY OF YOUR
LETTER RIGHT HERE.
RATHER THAN ME EXPLAINING IT, IT
WOULD BE BEST IF YOU DO.
>> IT'S GREAT THAT YOU REMEMBER
THE STORY.
AFTER THE MUELLER REPORT, WHICH
I CALLED THE MUELLER DOSSIER
DAME OUT.
-- CAME OUT.
I SAID WE WOULD COMB THROUGH.
IT THEY USED A GUARDIAN NEWS
REPORT TO CLAIM THAT THE CAMPUS
WAS A PLACE WHERE MISFUD WORKED.
WHAT THEY FAILED TO SAY IS THAT
MISFUD WAS ACTUALLY RELATED TO
ITALIAN INTELLIGENCE SERVICES.
IF YOU ARE MUELLER YOU HAVE TO
PUT THE ENTIRE PIECE BEFORE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
WE NOT DO THAT.
WE ARE CALLING HIM OUT.
THIS IS NOT HOW INVESTIGATIONS
ARE SUPPOSED TO BE BE RUN.
WHEN YOU LOOK INTO MISFUD CLOSER
YOU REALIZE HE IS CONNECTED WITH
ALL KINDS OF INTELLIGENCE AGENCY
INCLUDING OUR OWN FBI.
IN THAT LETTER, SEAN, YOU WILL
SEE THERE ARE PICTURES WITH FBI
AGENTS AT THE CAMPUS WHERE
MISFUD TEACHES AT.
WE WILL SUM IT UP.
WE WANT TO KNOW EVERY DOCUMENT
THESE AGENCIES HAVE RELATEED TO
MISFUD.
IF HE IS A RUSSIAN AGENT, IT
WOULD BE ONE OF THE BIGGEST
INTELLIGENCE SCANDALS FOR NOT
ONLY THE UNITED STATES BUT ALSO
OUR ALLIES LIKE THE ITALIAN AND
BLITZ AND OTHERS.
IF HE IS A RUSSIAN AGENT, HE
KNOW ABOUT OUR INTELLIGENCE
THROUGHOUT THE GLOBE.
WE WANT THOSE DOCUMENTS AND
GIVING THEM A WEEK.
RUSSIA.
MUELLER IMPLIES HE WAS A RUSSIAN
AGENT.
IT MAY BE MUCH DEEPER.
DO YOU BELIEVE IN AN EFFORT TO
ILLEGALLY SPY OR GET
INTELLIGENCE ON THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE THAT IT'S POSSIBLE THAT
SOME AT THE TOP OF OF OFF
INTELLIGENCE CHAIN UNDER OBAMA
AND BIDEN, THEY MAY HAVE
OUTSOURCED THINGS THAT WERE
ILLEGAL TO DO TO AMERICANS SO
THEY COULD HAVE OUR ALLIES DO
THE SPYING FOR THEM?
LET ME GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE.
GREAT BRITAIN OR AUSTRALIA OR
ITALY?
AM I OVER THE TARGET HERE?
>> I THINK YOU ARE.
ONE OF THE THINGS WE POINT OUT
IN THE LETTER, WE ARE VERY
SPECIFIC.
THE FBI OR THE MUELLER GROUP
CLAIMS THAT PAPADOPOULOS MISLED
THEM AND THEY WERE NOT ALLOWED
TO GET TO MISFUD IN TIME TO
INTERVIEW HIM.
THIS IS THE CLAIMS THEY MAKE
AGAINST PAPADOPOULOS WHEN THEY
SENTENCED HIM TO PRISON.
WHAT WE FOUND IS, WAIT A SECOND,
IF THIS REALLY HAPPENED, AND IF
YOU BACK TRACK, THEY ARE MAKING
THE CLAIM THAT MISFUD IS THE GUY
WHO SAID HE HAD EMAILS OR KNEW
THE INFORMATION ABOUT THE EMAILS
BEING IN THE HAND OF THE RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT.
IF THAT IS IN FACT TRUE, THEY
COULD NOT TALK TO MISFUD UNTIL
JANUARY OR FEBRUARY OF 2017.
WELL, HOW DID THEY KNOW TO ASK
PAPADOPOULOS ALL THROUGH 2016
WHETHER OR NOT HE HAD SEEN THE
RUSSIAN EMAILS OR KNOWS ABOUT
THEM?
THE ONLY WAY THAT'S POSSIBLE IS
THAT HAD TO COME FROM MISFUD
SOME WAY, SOMEHOW.
IT'S MORE LIKELY THAT I WILL BE
THE STARTING CENTER ON AN NBA
TEAM RATHER THAN WHEN MISFUD IS
A SECRET RUSSIAN AGENT.
WHO MISFUD IS WORKING FOR.
I DON'T KNOW.
WE HAVE TO BE SLOW AND PATIENT.
WHAT WAS THE RELATIONSHIP WITHIN
MISFUD AND OUR FBI AND OUR STATE
DEPARTMENT.
>> Sean: AND OUR INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY.
I WISH I HAD THOUGHT OF THIS
MYSELF.
THE MUELLER DOSSIER WHICH IS
INTERESTING.
YOU TALK ABOUT OMISSIONS IN THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL'S REPORT.
YOU ALSO TALK ABOUT -- EXPLAIN
HOW PAPADOPOULOS MET MISFUD.
THE STORY AND THE TALE WE KNOW
IS TRUE, EVEN THE "NEW YORK
TIMES" TRYING TO GET AHEAD OF IT
BECAUSE THEY KNOW IT'S COMING
OUT.
I DON'T KNOW LONG YOU YOU KNEW
BUT DIDN'T TELL ME.
THEY WERE USING A YOUNG,  FLIRTY
WOMAN IN THIS EQUATION TO SET
PAPADOPOULOS UP ALONG WITH THIS
PROFESSOR.
ANYTHING I AM SAYING IS WRONG
AND HOW DEEP CAN IT GO?
>> I SAID A YEAR AGO AND I WAS
MOCKED.
I SAID I AM NOT INTERESTED IN
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN WAS SPIED ON.
THAT'S FACT.
I WANT TO KNOW HOW SPIES OR
INFORMANTS WERE RUN INTO THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
LOOK.
THE "NEW YORK TIMES" STORY RIGHT
NOW SAYS TWO.
THAT'S UP FROM ONE.
MY GUESS IT'S A LOT MORE OTHER
THAN THAT.
IF YOU LISTEN TO WHAT THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR SAID
YESTERDAY, AS SOPHISTICATED AS
THIS OPERATION WAS TO HAVE A
FISA WARRANT ON SOMEONE THERE
HAD TO BE MORE INVOLVEMENT WITH
THE LEVEL OF PEOPLE.
I HOLD TO WHAT I SAID A YEAR
AGO.
I WANT TO KNOW HOW SPIES WERE
RUN INTO THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
I DON'T KNOW BUT WE WILL GET THE
ANSWER AND GET IT OUT TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> Sean: I COUNT 3 INSTANCES